han sido una noche y una mañana
especialmente violenta sentís Jordania y
Jerusalén este ocupados Empezando por
Jenny núcleo de resistencia Palestina
allí otra redada del ejército de Israel
provocó la muerte de dos palestinos El
primero un joven de la brigada de
jenning el segundo un médico el doctor
abdulla abu al Team que según la agencia
wafafa y el Ministerio de salud
palestino estabas ocurriendo a unos
heridos cuando recibió un disparo en la
cabeza no se ha podido confirmar el
origen de la bala pero las fuerzas
israelíes se limitaron a advertir que la
presencia de civiles no Implicados En
las zonas de combate supone un peligro
para la vida en esta redada fueron
detenidas tres personas entre ellas un
supuesto combatiente de jamás al que
Israel acusa de perpetrar ataques
recientes y a esto se suman otros dos
arrestados enredadas que han tenido su
réplica en hebrón y nabús por otra parte
aquí en Jerusalén se vivió otra noche de
enfrentamientos entre civiles palestinos
y fuerzas israelíes además de ata de
colonos judíos el episodio más llamativo
ocurrió en el barrio de xellarrat donde
los residentes palestinos denunciaron
daños en comercios y automóviles por
piedras lanzadas por colonos y hasta
allí acudió el parlamentario de
ultraderecha y tamar benguir de hecho el
también candidato a las elecciones del
primero de noviembre acudió con una
pistola y reclamó a la policía que
disparara contra los palestinos desde
hace seis meses Israel ha multiplicado
las incursiones en cisjordania ocupada
que las califica de antiterrorismo pero
a su vez Estas están causando que este
sea el año más mortífero desde 2015 con
118 palestinos muertos por fuego